how's that
anyone hear me now
yeah it wasn't an error it was just it
was just me being stupid
because i i didn't i i made a new scene
in obs and i did not um
i did not
uh
i just didn't add an audio source so
that's that
there's not not much more to it honestly
uh yeah
cool
so so i haven't actually no idea what
we're going to do today i just
thought maybe people are sitting
somewhere at home and
so
cool um
yeah i might not i might not
get all of chat so i'm sorry for that
it's
as we're as we're coding at the same
time this might not be super possible
but okay my my sort of goal today was to
get a little bit of um
to get a
bit of a hugging face tuning something
uh
going
so the idea is to
uh do question answering training maybe
make that into a little video later
but um i have no clue how this is going
to go also i got my trusty weights and
buys this cup here with
warm tea
this
the stream is not sponsored but
it is an awesome it is an awesome beaker
like
i've i genuinely don't like tea in like
these tiny cups that only hold like two
or three deciliters
it's it just sucks
okay what was the first machine learning
algorithm i implemented i i have no idea
honestly probably we had to implement
like support vector machines by hand
at some point
yeah
that was it
okay so
wait if i click on this the other thing
is going away
uh okay
maybe i can pop out chat here i'm trying
to to follow the chat as closely as i
can
forgive me for getting
not you need coffee oh yes there's one
other thing we need to do there's one
other thing and that is
one second
that is obviously we need to do a chroma
key
on the video right here no
yeah
is this even
not too bad like i can't see it in the
previewer i don't know if you see it or
not but obs is is screwing up so i can't
really see it but this seems fine right
you can see sort of through through me
all right
so
predictions someday at the lex friedman
podcast what's the story behind the
sunglasses i just put them on randomly
and then sort of that became my brand
no it's
i guess i'm not sure
i'm not sure that that was a wise choice
but it is what it is so okay the goal
let's say the goal the current goal is
uh
train
question
answering
let's do that
and i have not prepared this
so
the previous was nicer you mean this
screen but now you can see the screen
behind me so if something's here
you'll be able to see it
yeah but the settings might not be might
not be super good
one second
well these are polarized so i don't see
exactly too much
which route do you suggest passionate
product product management or ordinary
engineer
chat product manager
and beta ml engineer um
well do whatever you you have fun doing
it's uh people i feel people make make
too much uh
fuzz about career
choices and
i don't know it seems like you should
just do whatever you want to do
and as long as you have fun doing that
there's really nothing that can that can
go wrong
so
just do that
that seems
seems like the most logical thing
okay so what we're going to do is
a little bit that's yeah let's say we're
in the hogging phase and i have not
trained a hugging face model in a while
and this api keeps changing and
progressing so my first question is can
i i know there's this pipeline thing
what about training an answer question
instead
that's actually what we're going to do
so one of the techniques for getting
better question answering is to produce
questions from the answer which i hope
is what we might be able to do this now
so uh best way to get started with
machine learning
um
i don't know do some tutorials uh i
think
just whatever whatever you like there's
there's enough information out there
especially for beginners
oh no wait proper product placement i
need to hold it like this into the
camera
so refreshing
um so i know there's this
this pipeline thing right the question
is can i fine-tune a pipeline right can
i
um
can i fine-tune a pipeline or
essentially can i train a pipeline
but
or is this only for inference
so i don't know here under fine-tuning a
pre-trained model
um
can you train hogging face model with
cpu
sure but
do you have omni
omicron
i have no idea um
you can fine-tune a model right with
this trainer however uh the model would
be sort of
you know like a model like this so where
do they get the model from the model is
like a auto model for sequence
classification it is not a pipeline
and
the good thing about the pipeline
obviously is that it makes you know
things like loading data sets and and
stuff like this pretty pretty easy my
question is
where does the tokenizer come in right
here so
you see pre-process your data
input function
tokenize data sets so you need to set up
you need to set up the tokenizer
at the data sets
and then input the model as this model
right here so it seems like fine-tuning
a pipeline
might not be a thing
what hardware do you plan on using i'll
just do a collab for now
i guess that's my
that's gonna be my thing or even fully
fully locally
um yeah
all right
test trainer evaluation strategy
compile
fine tuning in native pi torch i don't
want to do that
i just want to do it with the trainer
with the trainer api that seems fine all
right um
let me quickly pull out a collab
or open a collab
and i'm sorry if sometimes i'm going to
pull stuff to the side right here
because i have no clue what's going to
pop up
all right we have one with the absolute
awesome name of untitled 2
we're gonna change that to hogging face
question answering
so
how much gpu size do you have currently
none
what do you mean by fine-tuning a
pipeline you can fine-tune the model
only yeah exactly you can fine-tune a
model but there's this pipeline
abstraction that sort of so if i
um maybe i can i can show you
so let's place this in here again right
there is this
pipeline
and
it takes care of a lot of stuff
so if you did question answering right
you can just load a model and the
tokenizer and what it would do
what it would do is
essentially it would
it would handle all of the
sort of plumbing around question
answering right
but
we don't
uh we're just gonna do it by ourselves
i think that's pipeline batching yeah
pipeline custom code
yeah
um
[Music]
implementing a new pipeline
no and then we have just
oh to use models for inference okay now
the question has been answered
all right
let's see
whether we can um
answering fine-tune
example
because we're not gonna
because we're not gonna do anything
ourselves we're just gonna use stuff
okay
i mean there must be there you go learn
how to fine tune a model for question
answering squad so this is going to be
our first thing we're going to fine-tune
model for question answering
then we're going to try to use
um
we're going to try to use
the
model that we've we've trained as a
baseline and we're going to try to train
another model that will generate
questions given some answers
and
then we're going to augment our data set
using those pairs and then hopefully
that will lead to a better data set
yeah i've seen papers
that do this in in
question answering especially natural
questions
and this has been really has been sort
of
improved but
or has been improving state of the art
but who knows
[Music]
i'm a student in need of compute for a
project
any advice for compute and in general
not really i mean there's there's collab
there's
there's quite cheap cloud compute and if
you are a student your university might
have
um
your university might have some
resources or
sometimes the big companies they give
sort of credits to university students
so
i don't know it might it might take a
bit of politics but you can usually get
stuff all right
let's see
i've as i said i haven't done this in a
long time so
yeah so we
squad we have a
tokenizer we need the distilbert okay
fine tune now we don't want tensorflow
okay this seems okay enough
sequence classification token
classification question answering
python notebook but there is already one
why do we open and why do we open a new
one
to be able to share your model with the
community now we don't want that all
right so let's start
yeah
okay
no need to log in but what we want to do
is
we also want to install 1db
because
um
how do we do that exactly
let's
check
yep
got it
and
code
this is just logging okay
i thought we have it
yeah
all right thank you
what's wrong
ah
very smart very smart
have
made it quiet
anyway okay so
we need to install git lfs
great
so what do we go here we're going to for
squad
v1 or v2
we're going to use distilbert batch size
of 16.
we're going to use the datasets library
which is pretty good
then
okay we're going to show some random
elements
pre-process fine-tune evaluation seems
easy enough we'll do that and we'll
figure out in the meantime what we need
to do in order to to go further
yep yep yep
uncomment the first time yes i i
i was i was absolutely able
okay appending
okay good so we're logged in nice
um
let me open let me open
let me open the 1db
[Music]
we'll figure it out once we log
something right
i guess we can just run all now
all right this looks good so far we got
probably the same random examples and so
here you see how this this data set is
built
this is made from wikipedia articles so
the the the dataset creators they always
sort of grabbed a paragraph from
wikipedia i think it's always kind of
the first one
not sure so
i don't know carrot
i think it's always this one but i'm not
entirely sure uh it might be anyone but
i think i'm also not sure if of the
exact differences between squad v1 and
v2
uh
however
that's kind of uh yeah
do you have your own gpu workstation or
university so our university had a
cluster
they built it up during my phd which is
which is fairly big
um but our group also had sort of our
own
own gpus
um yep
no where were we
so yeah this is sort of a paragraph
this is i guess the id of the sort of
the title
of the um
of the
article in wikipedia and then there is a
question like what was proclaimed the
state religion under theod
theodosius the first
and then there is an answer and
the answer is somewhere in the text so
it's extractive um
extractive question answering
and
you can see here christianity or sorry
nascene christianity is the correct
answer now the answer might actually
be multiple
time mentioned multiple times in the
paragraph
and it is important that you not only
get the answer correct but you get the
correct index so you also need to decide
which if it's mentioned multiple times
which of the mentions is the correct one
and that would be sort of the one that
directly answers the question
so
it's pretty strict and um
but it's
so
this is close domain extractive question
answering it has sort of a reputation of
being a lot about kind of keyword
finding and sort of comparing the model
doesn't need to understand that much
about
uh
yeah the question is out of frame what
what oh
why does this keep happening thank you
no wait
huh
okay
i'm out of frame too
look at that
[Music]
all right how do i fix this
another frame
okay so
isn't youtube 16x9
because i'm streaming 16x9 if you see
like here in obs right
you can see
oh no okay it's the side of
it's the side of the the screen here
okay we might be able to fix this uh
there's there's probably a crop
somewhere going on
you see there's nothing here obs is
screwing this up
crop right there's no crop right
none
so i don't know what's what's going on
all right we'll just have to live with
it
i think this is obs not not handling
uh the screen resolutions well
in any case
oh yeah you can see me totally fine
right i was confused about that
all right sorry
so the answers if you're able to see
them i'll try to make it a little bit
more
inside
uh the answer right here is a string and
also an index into the text so 169 and
i'm going to guess that points to
sort of this piece right here
all right so
this is the data set
and uh pre-processing the training data
consists of what consists of
instantiating the tokenizer um
then you can see that
we
tokenize
on two sentences one for the answer one
for the context okay
and depending on your model we'll see
different keys
yeah okay so
what's this what is your no this is
beginning of sentence right
um 102 what's 102
what is your name is maybe this run
right here then it's sort of the end of
sentence
and then it's another um
my name is silva
and then it's another end of sentence
that's this tokenization the attention
mask is there okay
so we can feed
things to this tokenizer with a max
length
then what we do is we go through the
data set
let's find a long example
oh this is just exploring
if we just truncate we'll lose
information so we need to go sort of
in a stride over the data set but the
tokenizer is doing this for us
now we have a
list of input ids okay so we split up
each the context if it's too long into
these these different things into these
different
chunks and we iterate over the data set
you can see that the question is always
the same
but
for the context
will will truncate the second or will
stride over the second thing so here is
the men's basketball team has over yada
yada yada yada
and if you're at the end here
well that is a long context
um you see the 32 wins were
that is the end
and that is not the beginning here
the beginning is championship
so if i i'm going to guess if you go on
here you're going to see the 32 wins
somewhere in yeah you see here the 32
wins were the most so it's kind of
striding over this document
any new machine learning street talk
episode coming
uh
yes yes there is one coming where we're
working on it
um
when do you release a udemy course no no
i don't have these stamina to create a
a course
um
and i i think other people are are
better at that
but who knows
i don't know
udemy curse no not yet
not yet
uh
okay
this will give us
we need to find which of those features
the answer is where exactly the models
will you require to start an end
position
to map parts of the original context to
some tokens thankfully the tokenizer can
help us by returning an offset mapping
this gives for each index of our input
ids the corresponding start and end
character in the original text that gave
our token that's pretty useful
is this how new is this because i
remember having to do this myself which
was awful
um or i just didn't know about this
the very first token has zero zero
because it doesn't correspond to any
part of the question answer the second
token is the same as the characters zero
to three of the question
uh the how here that is one token
and
so that goes from zero to three and then
the next token goes from four to eight
four would be many to eight you can see
that the white space is sort of falling
away so not every character is covered
by an id
this is pretty useful
um
yep
oh that's what they they do right here
so
first token id
input ids okay we get this
offsets we get this
then
we uh get the token
and we also get it from the question you
can see that it's almost the same but it
has been
lowercased
um yeah to anyone who's new will train
question answering but will also just
i've not i've now prepared
also
chatting
let's do that
hmm
okay
yeah i'll kick the bot
or he did
cool all right so
so we can use this mapping to find the
position of start and end tokens
i have to distinguish which part of the
offset correspond to the question which
correspond to the context sequence ids
okay the sequence id says zero and one
for the question in the context
respectively it returns none for the
special tokens
okay
so if we now have an answer let's say we
have an answer
and the answer start which is the index
right into
into the
which is the index
into the text
the end
character we can figure out by simply
taking the length of this answer
and adding it to the start
and what we're going to do now
start token index of the current span in
the text
so we're simply going to loop over
the entire thing until we reach
the second thing so you know here is the
question and here is the context so
we're going to loop until we hit one
which is the first token
um
and then we're going also to find the
end index of that
we're going to the end here and we're
going from the end we're subtracting
negative one until we reach okay
that's that's cool
then we're going to
detect if the answer is out of the span
in which case this feature is labeled
with the cls
index
there's a lot of like plumbing to do
right
if the offsets
of the start token in of the token start
index so now we're going to look at
these offsets
so where in the original text
is a given token
if that's outside of the
um
starting
character which we have right here so if
that is
smaller
okay so if the answer
is somewhere after
the start index so if the answer is
somewhere after this one and somewhere
before the last one right over here
then we have the answer in this context
otherwise we don't
and this code here is to figure out
where exactly the answer is in that
we can double check that it's indeed the
theoretical answer
so what we're going to do is we're going
to look at the answer that's given from
the data set and then we're also going
to tell the tokenizer to decode from the
start position to the end position
in the input ids
and we got it cool
okay
so we also tell it to pad right
let's put everything together in one
function we will apply to our training
set
in the case of impossible answer the
answer another feature in another
context we set the cls index for both
the start and the end position we could
also simply discard those examples from
the training set
if the flag allowing possible answers is
false
okay
all right so this is prepare train
features we're going to
will explain how to handle long texts
for train and inference
yeah that's what they do right here
right they they simply set this stride
right here
and um so they stride over the context
that's what they do in the tokenizer so
the tokenizer is going to emit
always the question and then a part of
the document and this part is strided
over the document and then for each one
you're trying to figure out
where the answer is in the context and
if the answer is inside you try to
figure out where if the answer is
outside you you'd simply say this the
answer is nowhere in here which you
dummy encode as saying the cls token is
the correct answer
so
um
which gives you also an indication of
whether or not the question is
unanswerable
which is going to be important in later
data sets for example natural questions
has questions that are sort of
unanswerable
and having sort of a this this gives you
like an immediate classifier
so that's how i guess how you do it
what's the best way to de-tokenize text
i don't know give it to the tokenizer
and say
say uh
decode
right here
okay so here we put everything together
um
okay this
pad on right
max length stride return overflowing
tokens true i don't know if that mapping
is true ah this is what you need to put
to get these mappings
padding we pad to the max length
okay and now for each
now we loop offset mapping
so here we get a dictionary
and we're going to get
the offset mappings out of it
and we're going to fill
other entries here it's calling start
positions and end positions
okay i guess we can skip over that but
at the end we're going to end up with
sort of a a dictionary
that i guess we can look at it right
here
nope
okay this is uh
we can't we can't this is not a global
variable
all right but in any case
we have ah this one here features
features is
a dictionary no a batch encoding
but they should be
the same ish as a dictionary
does this work yeah exactly so we have
input ids which is or the samples
what t do you have
weights and bias is tea obviously
it's a
some kind of berry tea you can activate
vim on colab
[Music]
let me
figure that out
i've knew i've known this but i somehow
don't like
i don't like
i'm not too too much of a fan
of
vim bindings in other things
i'll try where
view tools
settings
there we go
um
okay
good we have
we have vim bindings
all right
not too big of a fan because i i don't
have all my
key bindings like my vim rc
it's not the same
all right and finally finally we'll have
a tokenized data set
by applying the map function to data
sets
all right
and then we instantiate the model from
the checkpoint where is this where does
this come from see now i search for it
and i don't know i don't know where it
is right
um so i need to search like this
and
where is it
ah that's on top here
it's just not not too pleasant of an
experience to have in bindings
but
continue
so we'll load up the model like this
from the checkpoint right then um we'll
have some training arguments right here
yada yada push to hub no
um
yeah exactly
so
okay we've instantiated our trainer and
now we can just say train
and
if this is
working out all we should be able
to see this in our 1db
um
dashboard
there we go
wait
let me
break out the tab here
do we have an accelerator even
um
runtime
type
we do not
all right let's try again
run time
[Music]
restart and run all
so in the meantime we can think of what
do we do in order to actually
uh
do what we came here to do namely
um
wait
is this on a custom data set no it's on
squad squad is a question answering data
set so what we want to do is we want to
actually
take
the squad data set and generate more
questions from it so what we need to do
is we need to train a model to take in
a um
a context
and an
answer
and give us the question right
this is is different
so
it's a bit like um we actually need to
do
generation of
text and not just question answering and
we can take that data set and feed it
back into the question answering so how
do we do that
um
we need some sort of a text
generation
model
so we go on to the
hub let's say
here we have examples
fine tuning
with custom data sets
um
sequence what's this
sequence classification token
classification question answering
it's all along the along the same lines
but what we need to do is a text
generation right so um
train
and
what do we want maybe a t5 or so or or
maybe a gpt-2
some some model like this we could we
could
generate so maybe we'll start real small
with like a distil gpt or something
and we'll fine-tune it
okay
so let's take that can we fine-tune the
distill
gpt probably
or do we have to fine-tune gpt and then
that's we already had this
how to fine tune a model on
yeah
okay
translation
summarization
speech recognition
audio classification
language modeling
which one i guess the translation
might be most appropriate to us no
since
since um what we want to do is we have
like an input like it's a sequence to
sequence task
and can we already see anything no
but we're training
but we don't see anything yet
let's see
ah there we go
hey
where are me charts
we only have that yet we didn't actually
log anything yet okay
but
okay we have a gpu now that's good
yeah see there's no
no epoch yet i mean this is it's gonna
take a while
i have a feeling it's gonna take a while
right
it's just five hours look at that
okay in the meantime we need to we need
to figure out um what to do
so where do we need to hook in
um
where do we need to hook in
why not question answering we're doing
question answering we're just doing it a
little bit weird
where do we hook in in order to find
so i feel the
um
i feel
the data set here is just fine right we
get
input ids which contains
this contains the
but do we really need
to point
so if we give it
if we give it
start and end positions those are the
labels
input ids
the point with these transformers is you
can always you can give them right you
can you can give them
a
part
of the input
as labels like what we had as the
sequence ids before
these are zeros and ones and usually you
do
zeros for like
the um
for the
first sentence and ones for the second
sentence or here you do zeros for the
question and once for the context
can we somehow abuse this to mark the
answer probably not
maybe what we need to do is
we need to give it the
context the answer and then produce the
question but in an autoregressive way
i'm late can someone shortly explain
what we're trying to achieve so we're
just we've just analyzed this notebook
here that fine tunes
um
question answering and we're seeing now
that it's just going to take way too
long
but the goal is to
take this and actually produce
questions new questions so we're going
to train a date this model
that takes in the context then the
answer
and then
gives us
a question
so that is
that is the goal right here and for that
we are looking at
fine-tuning
fine-tuning a
translation model
fine-tuning a pre-trained model common
downstream tasks
here we're going to fine-tune a
translation model
but the tokenizer
this is very very much into
translation this is another sentence
can we fine-tune a t5
um
is that too big of a model
t5 see people have done this before
ah
they used they used
this is an old version
classification
sentiment span extraction
summarization okay
so we could potentially
use this right here
is full stack advantage
okay
attractive summer
yep so
this and that
we got a gpu
what are they doing here
custom data set
so we're
outputting our settees
target ids
does this still run
i wonder
let's just
sort of
let's just sort of stop this right here
interrupt
and let's give this a try
too many sessions yeah just
okay
good stuff
wow this is
this is training
by hand
so essentially all we need to do is we
need to get the squad data set and we
need to replace the summary
we need to explain
replace the the summary
source
with the context and answer and then the
summary target with the question
this should be
okay-ish
um
i have done this already now
sorry i need
to log in briefly into 1db
just putting somewhat something else in
my
control c
in my clipboard
okay
so
we got an error this might be an old an
old thing
sentence piece library
we can do that
yep
did
so now we just splice the two together
where is loader train okay
this goes from a data frame
probably be easier if we do
we did the um
so we need these
source mask
and here we need source mask as well
target ids source ids and source
mask
you also need a tokenizer
so i feel we can copy over the data set
from the last one
okay
good so now we
we don't
have the data set which is fine
d5 for conditional where does this come
from
have you tried comet
i have not tried comet i'm sorry
t5
for conditional generation that's what
we need
with the language modeling head on top
yes
so input ids
position embeddings
from a t5 tokenizer
what about target
returns loss
labels ah there we go
no this is sequence classification
how can we compute the loss if we have
batch size sequence length
how do we compute a loss exactly if we
don't have targets
like
ah here label
so you just give
okay
i guess we can do that
all right so here here's what we do
we'll do a new
collab as we add it here
we'll just make our own
and we'll click click click together
whatever whatever we need
so
this is probably going to yell at us no
okay
do we have the gpu
change runtime type gpu yes
it's going to yell at us we're going to
terminate the others
and close
i've just started a job and your channel
is a common source of inspiration thank
you
i hope i'm not destroying that today
because live streams are are quite a bit
more
more boring
but we'll try our best
yes
okay
good
we'll so we get the data set and then we
get this
we'll we'll just try that we'll try the
t5 thing that they have here
so this is for inference
this is for
yeah we can do this this is fine
the vim bindings still here no they're
not um
tools settings
editor
film
so
okay we still need sentence peace
excellent
favorite beer
i uh
i don't i don't have a i don't drink
beer
so
i've no idea sorry
okay
tokenizer
we
wait we can't get
pre-trained token this is impossible
what's our tokenizer
none our tokenizer is none
[Music]
let's grab this
put it down here
and
see my bindings don't work
this is annoying
how can this how can it be
all right help me here why is this why
is it none why is the tokenizer done
have you experienced impostor syndrome
like long periods without published
papers how did you go through yeah i
think yeah this is quite unless you're
like super stellar at academia this is
very very common
um
yeah it's
it's like it it seems like everyone else
knows more
than you and
you can't like you just can't let it get
you down
and also a lot of research fails right
but
i mean i think for most people the
answer is just to prevail there it might
be a little bit
tricky if you have like if you really
have a wrong topic that where it's
really hard to publish stuff yeah but
i'm just seeing that
no not again sorry need to get a quick
power
see this previously happened on live
stream where i was streaming and my
battery just kept decreasing
in power
and now i even have the
big charger here
but when i did the minecraft stream that
was the case so even though it was
plugged in it would just slowly decrease
in in in battery over time
so i might have to stop it might just
break at some point and i'm i'm really
sorry
um but
yeah
we'll see how long this lasts
okay
in any case did we figure out did we
figure out why
the tokenizer here is
none
maybe we have a wrong one so
up t5 small
right
i mean this should be
should be okay no
maybe ah we can get an auto tokenizer
all right instead of a
an auto tokenizer instead of using the
t5 class
seems reasonable enough
so
like this
let's take this put it here
um
that's better okay
all right
see none of the swim stuff is working
i if i if i cut
if i
cut this and
okay i can paste it but
i like it i have i don't have my my zero
buffer
aren't you afraid that your search
history will pop up when you type the
search for
yes yes i'm afraid well i'm afraid i
mean it will pop up but i'm not i'm not
that interesting of a
i don't think my searches are
interesting enough to warrant big worry
um
yeah
i i'm rather
what are we working on we're trying to
make a model that
that gives us questions to answers
which
so let me update the text right here
current goal
just chatting also training model that
okay
all right
so now let's look at our loss
our loss should be a number
prediction scores
are something
1 7 32 that's probably the vocabulary
that's probably the
length
i guess
because the input ids what's the
input ids should be a tensor
of length seven
all right
so and then we can use the
second line right here in order to
conditional
regeneration from pre-trained that's the
same line that's the same line that's
the same line
and
there we can generate stuff from it
the outputs here are
so
let's give it to
helps
decode
[Music]
list cannot be interpreted as an integer
how about that
yep so there you go that is uh
hello my dog is cute
wait hello my dog is cute
uh
no
shouldn't we sort of autoregressively
and
shouldn't we be able to generate text
from this i have no idea how this how
this works
generate inputs max length min length do
sample
early stopping uh
let's let's put 10 here
so
cute and cute
use batch decode yes
true absolutely
very cool
all right so we can force it to to
create something now we need a data set
and we'll copy this from here we'll get
the squad data set
data sets
do we have data sets over here
we have data sets cool
we'll get the squad data set load
data set
squad let's just go with squad
um
datasets is not defined
all right
good let's just remind ourselves and
mostly me
how this works
okay
yeah so this is all
this is all good
i used to we used to all do all of this
by hand right like load the data and
process pre-processed stuff and yada
yada
so and this has been it's gotten so much
easier recently it is it is crazy
um
so we'll get the training data set and
this is an indexable right this is not
just an interval yeah
so it's technically what we can do is um
how does this map work right here
map
right we can we can do this um
this map function
no
yep
do this map function
and what it does is you can give it
a
like
takes a callable accepting addict as an
argument and iterates over the data set
by calling the function with each
example
so that's what we do
we'll map it
or how do we how do we then train
how do we train
trainers are trained so we got the model
we have a date to set and how does the
dataset need to be structured for
training that's my my only other
question
so
like how do we how do we know what the
the loss is
imdb
tokenize
function so we tokenize it
but then what's the
how do we tell the model
what the
label is
we just give it the data set but
is that just like inherent in this data
set
because uh here you see map
so
we return we
map the tokenize tokenize the data sets
small train data set
right this is what i don't get so we
simply extract the text
we tokenize it which is cool which is
fine right
but then we only have the
text um
how does it know what the labels are
labels
now this is for evaluation
report
metrics report
metrics
this must be inherent to the data set
somehow
auto returned by tokenizer okay
okay
i see
cool
so if
if we transform this right now so let's
make a function
um
dev uh
process data because why not because
i feel like implementing a touring
machine every function can be called
process data
um
so this is going to be an example right
here
we
we pass and
at the end we'll just um
we'll pass in the zero f data point
right here
all right so
if we do this we'll just get our normal
our normal
thing
now what we need to do is we need to get
the context
the answer and the question
and for the context and the answer
let's just concatenate them
um
yeah
we'll do it we'll do the cheapest we'll
do like the gpt3
uh cheap trick right here so
process data of data yeah
that's what we're gonna do
okay so we'll we'll do the
um input
uh
text is
let's put the
context right here
um
and
we'll do we'll do gpt3 style we'll do
context colon
of this
and
we'll do
answer colon
i know t5 does things differently a
little bit
but
we don't care
example
answers
we have multiple and we could have
multiple answers but we'll just take
whatever the first one is
so
the answer
um
text
zero
like that
so this is going to be our input
and then
this one right here is the prompt
output text is going to be
simply the question
all right
now we need a the tokenizer
the tokenizer
um we have it somewhere up right good
oops oops oops
see what did i do
encode
the input text
so these are going to be the input ids
do we need a mask
we can give it two things
can we also give the t5 thing two things
maybe not
tokenizer
probably not it's gonna be fine right
this right here
encode
return tensors
pt will do that
um
let's just do this once okay
so the input ids is going to be
good
could we
put a second one here like what
what happens if we do this
then is are these two lists now
let's see
this is
the tensor bracket
anyone see whether these are two lists
probably not right
so if we do this the last one is is a 10
and then if we do
this
the last one is not ah here is 10 1
and then there is 304 something
something okay
i mean we could just do language
modeling as such right
and
we could then even let it figure out the
answers
but that's kind of crappy because we
would also train it to do the context
t5 is encoder yeah t5 is encoder decoder
you must specify the decoder input plus
pad plus
plus label
yeah so the
the the query the queue here
would probably be
the part of the decoder
like here it's we're going from a t5
this is okay this is pandas
this is validation down here
we have target ids and source ids for
this one right
so
input ids
we don't have
if input id's decoder input ids is
this
and lm labels
is what language model labels
so here we have input ids
the attention mask
encoder outputs
here decoder input ids that's i guess
also what we what we want for the
decoder
provide for sequence sequence training
uses the path token ideas this starting
token for decoder input ids generation
if
take a look at t5 training there we go
we could use those extra ids right
ah
unsupervised denoising training
supervised
training translate english to german
the house is wonderful
labels
return tensors
easy enough easy enough
thank you for thank you for letting me
letting me know
um
so we put our end of of sentence here
then we put
let's
do this
yep
and our end of sentence here
input ids labels
uh
output text
pie torch tensors let's remove this one
and we should be good to go
so input ids
and
labels
excellent excellent
where was it
where was t5 training
too many tabs open
supervised training
okay if we put this into the model now
do we get a loss that's the question if
we get a loss everything's fine
everything's good
so where is our model
model
um
let's call this x because why not
my coding voice is very different yeah
because i can't i can't keep up hours of
shouting
um
so
what if we put x into the model
that that is not cool okay what if we
put
well if we unpack x into the model
that is better
better
better better better
what is this what's ah
holy crap
okay um
let's call this y
and let's look at
type of why
investigate
sequence to sequence language model
output thank you that is very helpful
um what can i
is it addict
yes it is okay so we have a loss
we have a loss
i guess that is
why do you always wear shades so people
ask the question
is branding he's just branding
okay so we have this
very cool
um
now
so
if we do this we can even see it
now we can use our data set
map
process data what do they do here
um
i guess we can use
patched and we can you we can we can
remove
all the columns now
we can probably remove all the columns
module object is not subscript remove
columns
data sets uh this is it
is not happy it's not very happy
list indices must be integers or slices
well
ah okay we should do batched false
all right i guess we should also drop
we should probably also drop some of the
too long stuff now
i mean that's what they
that's what they do here they put a max
length
return overflowing tokens
ah we don't we don't
we don't want that we simply want the
max length right
um
so
nope stop it
stop it
okay
so
tokenizer
um
see now is the the trouble right the max
length is what
the max length is what for t5 small does
anyone know
let's see t5
or can i figure can i figure this out
somehow is there there should be this
auto there's this auto config no by
hogging face
um
can i load this somehow
somehow
here like
there is
auto config
from
pre-trained
t5 small
no this should exist
yeah see
so here
we have
task specific parameters
model type number of positions number of
layers
task specific parameters
vocab size
translation
summarization
max length
is this though
is this the max length
of the encoder or the decoder
i mean here it's 5 12.
we can do the following
we can do
we can do max length here to something
i mean what is
what is 5 12 let's say minus 128
okay and then
and then here we can do
padding equals
how about that
so we pad
everything
max length min length
230 yeah thanks
thank you
so
we'll see we'll we'll we'll
make everything such that it is at max
512 long we can still change these
things we should probably like make some
some variables somewhere but
so um
good now that the data set is mapping
what can we do
i guess all we have to do is give it to
the to the trainer no
hugging face trainer
compute loss here and then
do we have examples right here
sec 2 sec trainer
can we just
get a trainer or we do we need the
specific one
evaluate no predict no
training arguments
that is a
model
we put in model
yep
train data set eval data set
yeah this should be doable no
here
trainer we just give it
this
and we're good
really
we could make it even smaller
given that
it's going to take a while
also
um
we could just do this let's just cancel
for now how long does it take
what
but they did it they did it up here
they did it here no they made this
smaller data set
um
what do i need to do
no
yeah here here is a data set
okay i guess they just took the training
one
like this
okay
excellent
so now we have a data set and we should
just be able to give this to a trainer
yes
okay so let's get some
some of them training arguments
good
and let's also get some of them
trainer
itself
good
ah yeah okay three that's where the 384
comes from thank you
um
okay model is model this is that
and i guess
okay
so
um and
this
and that good
so here we have
train data set and eval data set
this seems to work so far this is more
like magic
how
where is all of this
like code like okay
there seems to be so much magic going on
and this this is
okay i see finally finally we get
something
um
something that
crashes
so
what did we do
input shape too many values to unpack in
the input shape
so where are we going wrong
two big context now we have um
we have too many
things so here we might be
we might want to inspect this x a little
more so these are our input
ids right so
input ids are right here
and if we do
the shape of them
we get
two numbers
now this is complaining that if it looks
at the input shape right
so if we go to t5 modeling
wow
this opens in a collab directly
this is crazy
okay if we go to the input shape
this is the input embeddings
no that's not true see the input ids
oopsie
dot size
well what is it are you aren't you gonna
tell me too many values to unpack well
what is it
so
maybe we need maybe we need to batch
this ourselves somehow right
because uh
here you as you can see the shape where
was it is 1
and 384
so this already assumes that it's kind
of batched
and um
if i'm i i might be completely wrong
right here
unpack is about the input shape being
only one object
try printing the shape
yeah
i can print can i print in here
but it seems the problem is the batching
though
so
does this work
this seems weird it like if this works
this is
this is magic
i've not
developed in a collab in so long
no right this does not this does not
work so if
all change is saved yeah
ah okay
now it says too many values too yeah i
did not load reload this thing can i
sorry
click the six frames
yep well
it just tells me where it's happening
which i know right i just
compute loss
models unpack the inputs that's fine
i think it's the um
[Music]
the collate
function is wrong it assumes that what
comes out of the data set is
a single example so it probably batches
it together
you need to use auto reload too
thank you
let's try
auto reload
magic function not phoned
too bad
it probably assumes that so what we
could do is we could um
simply tell it that this is not a
batched thing
right
i found at least two devices
great now we're
okay
process data
uh
how about that
there's no attribute detached
ah
yeah okay
sounds good um
we'll try again
too many values to unpack
still no
yeah it still thinks it's there
but it it doesn't matter we have bigger
problems we
we have bigger problems look at this
thing um
now where was it
here
right so
we need to
do we really need to get back which ones
are on
you need to run auto
after load ext
okay okay okay okay
okay so see i'm so unfamiliar
with collabs
because i've just been using my vim in
my terminal
that i have no clue about the magic
functions
okay
so
there yeah there you go exactly so this
is what i meant it as it batches it to
eight it assumes that what comes out of
the data set is already
um
a batch
and therefore
it doesn't it it doesn't
doesn't get it so either
we somehow tell like the tokenizer or
something that or we tell the
the collate function
uh
collater default
we'll patch our processed examples
together
let's see
there's the default one
label
ids handles a list of values
per object
maybe this one data collater for sick to
sec
tokenizer
dynamically pad the inputs as well as
the labels maybe this one's good for us
so let's try this one
you code in whim yes i'll make a video
about my vim config
okay all tensors need to be on the same
device found at least two devices
how can i how can i where where is my
where's my data set so how about
how about i look at
you know what's x
what is x dot
input ids
what's the
device of that
ah
cpu okay
so
how how how how
how do i how do i put that on
and x is what x is just
x is a data point
now
can i just tell
hogging face to
or do i have to actually say
um
did the model have a device
okay
so now what we'll have to do is we'll
have to
input ids equals x input ids
to small device
and labels equals
x labels
to model device
yeah okay so now we got sort of the same
we got the same
problem here
so we don't want to necessarily
do this
we want to output this because
after a while we could also overflow and
then output several
could we
several different ones
now i guess we can continue doing this
and then here we'll just have to
do
something like that or expand
we'll just go
none
like do a little unsqueeze
nice okay
so
now we're still in
oh no
now we have we have we need to remove
the print statement again otherwise
we'll just be bombarded by print
statements right
okay
let's do this
let's do that
please save thank you
okay
good
problem solved
happy holiday thank you happy holiday to
you too
good we're at the next error
expected a sequence length of 384 at
dimension one got 517.
what
we even limited it to
we limited this
got 512
data collateral
um
we're here
label do we have label or label ids
we have label we should have label ids
now
because
yeah
we should have label ids
that seems reasonable
still the same okay
so the problem is
that here
what's f
in features
uh
what's features
what is it
a list of dict
f of k so what's k
if k is not in label
and v is not none
and here we say expected the sequence of
length got okay
um
we can do this and we can print the
length of that and let's see what
happens
384 384 384
and then we get like a long one
why is it not respecting
the max length
um
so
this one
let's see
why is it not respecting the max length
um
hmm
yes max length pad to max length
max length
i'm just searching for this now
in all the in all the things i have open
yeah i should be able to truncation true
is that a thing okay
let's see
auto models
tokenizer
pre-trained tokenizer
can i click on it
please
yes
no
oh this is version two
um
sure
there we go max length
it's called model max length really
truncation
defaults to false well that explains
something
let's in this case do
true
how about now
384 384 384
this looks better okay
now we just need to remove
the print statements
otherwise the file will be gone
cool
okay so this isn't too long this isn't
five hours like before
so hopefully
um
hopefully
something
cool will happen if you drunk it you
throw away everything after the first
384 tokens is that on purpose yes
um we can still refine like that
keep these tokens that it's handled in
that yeah the tokenizer can sort of
split and and um
tokenizer can stride over the document
but in first instance i'm just happy
with getting any sort of result
can still be refined later but
we just want to train anything at all
well this is the fun part so
i think
people sometimes ask you know about
streaming and machine learning
and um
you know streaming video games is sort
of the
the most like super entertaining right
because it's like stuff is happening and
then streaming coding is still okay if
you can
talk and code and read chat and so on at
the same time
but then streaming
machine learning is just sort of
even even if we make the data sets
deliberately small like we did here
it is just
it is it is we just have to wait
and then what do we do during during
waiting
could you show line data set equals um
data set equals well we have data set is
simply
loading it here from we simply load the
squad data set
so
that's kind of trivial but then we
have this mapping function here
that tokenizes the text
and
puts it into sort of this
this
framework
context and answer and we want to output
the question
what do you do during wait normally
i i watch i love watching
loading
bars and screens
but usually i uh
i don't know i code something else
i guess there is something else to code
which which is uh i'm i'm making like a
super
sure doing an ama
am i not doing an ama during all of the
live stream
sword fight
yes the xkcd meme
so i see a score if i have enough gpu
left that's a tight rope no
try to stream some reinforcement
learning
watch an agent not really working yeah
if you get the visualization set up
correctly that could be something also
like
smaller problems right like way smaller
problems is also is also something this
here i i sort of wanted to to try and oh
we can we can look at our we can look at
the um
this here it should be yeah
yeah
look at
this at least the cpu utilization is
is going on
that is something that's happening
we don't have metrics yet we might want
to log more intermittently training
completed
training completed excellent we have we
have zero
logging we did log right it said it logs
to
it logs to report to
yada dada
didn't it say it would lock to weights
and biases
did we even log in
on
db we didn't log in
we didn't log in
um
oh we did
somewhere
at some point maybe
am i planning to do the ml
year recap video
did i announce an emma review
recap
i don't know alpha fold happened or
something was it this year or last year
i have no idea uh
the paper of the year
no idea
it's really hard to predict what paper's
going to have
a big impact
um for example the
foundation models paper
it can either have a really big impact
or it can just
be forgotten by everyone there's like no
no way to tell right now
um
yeah
what do you think about the recent hype
and graph neural nets i've not looked
super much into graph neural nets it
seems it seems they're they're pretty
cool but
um they're also seem to be quite limited
right now because
i mean they're essentially
n's on on a dynamic graph
check the report yeah so 1db has
1db has a
trainer
so
there should be it should be possible
here report to 1db
that's fine
but um
uh with the training arguments
good stuff
um we might want to restart and run all
okay
now once the model has trained
we can then let it
generate some stuff i i really don't
think
i don't think that
it will produce something interesting
right now but
okay
okay good stuff
reusing the data set
that's what we want
okay here yes
this one
okay as this is going to come in
we can already think about what we want
to do
so
what we want to do
is we want to
simply take
the model that we have and let it
generate something again
so
let's just try
let's just try this again
i
think
no
no like
try this and where was the generate
here
and then we do batch decode
there we go
aren't graft neural networks just a year
behind nlp or attention
i'm not sure what a year behind
you mean the like in a year they're
going to be as popular
it could be
i've also seen like there's also a big
history of of such things just flopping
like there being a lot of
hype and then
not much
it depends it depends if
if um
sort of
large
breakthroughs i guess are being made in
relevant domains that's usually what
fuels these things like transformers
i think bert vertez
transformers have existed and i remember
i remember people sort of the sentiment
was
yeah transformers for language they kind
of work but they use so much memory and
they're harder to train and
so on and and people would still sort of
be on the
be on the fence and and say we'd rather
use
lstms
uh with attention
and i think only the advent of bert
really so it wasn't even the attention
is all you need paper it was it was the
birth paper that really
fueled
the um
that the transformer hype
so if there is
something similar
for graph neural networks in in a
relevant domain
so either in a domain that exists
like but i don't i don't really see
graph neural networks being that useful
in vision or
or nlp or something
so i'm not entirely sure they are
probably super useful in biology
uh but it's not like biology is
that
it's just not that accessible to most
people and and they don't want to work
in biology because if if i'm good at
like if i do something in nlp like i can
build a little app and so on uh it's
very tangible and very useful for most
people
and same with vision but with something
like biological data i mean yeah sure i
can download some bio data from from
online but then
uh
you know what
what what am i going to do with it
are you familiar with p-i-n-s no
i'm not actually
sucks
1db socks giveaway
well if you if you if i'm
i don't know i should wear them probably
yeah
[Music]
sorry i'm trying to keep up with chat
most interesting meta learning paper
i've i i'm not i'm not super i don't
have a
maybe not anyone but i don't have a good
overview over metal learning
according to elite or graph neural
networks are largely nlp research from
2019 and 2020 and if you want to chief
soda
you'd have to use
20 20.
uh so you're you're saying that
current nlp methods
um beat
the graph neural network methods so
when people in the past said hey these
graph neural networks are actually
pretty good
then all you have to do
essentially is wait a year and then the
field would have sort of caught up
i guess i hope that's what
you're saying um
okay so now we're we're sort of kind of
a bit ready no
yes
so
here um
let's say
yes we we can generate a context hi
uh
the dog was loud
and
um
the answer is dog right and then end of
sentence
okay and then we have
yes
does that does that work
okay so
input ids and then we'll put them
to
device
like this
how about this
you have to
either decoder input ids okay
so
and code
let's encode just the
i
see
huh
what am i gonna what am i gonna put here
how do i how do i have t5 answer a
question then
um
no
how
will there be yonic merch sometime soon
yes
there is there's merge it's
i mean i'm still i'm still fleshing out
the merge right i'm i'm still this is a
changing thing if you i guess you can
have it today
um
but
i'm just telling you this is it's going
to change so
if you're into super rare stuff
um
maybe it's going to be deleted soon it's
also going to be augmented but
let me
uh let me show you
done
[Music]
yeah okay it's up
so
but as i said this is subject to change
um
and and so on but if you so you can
either go here
or you can go
the url is um
is store.whyculture.com
that's it that should be a redirect
to the
it's a teespring store
so and it's going to be integrated with
super rare super rare in the sense that
i might decide something is just too
dumb of an item and just remove it again
because i need to thin it out a little
bit
uh but you know
no one stops you from just taking like
if you if you really let's say i remove
this t-shirt right no one stops you from
just taking the channel logo and
slapping it on a t-shirt yourself it's
it's going to be
literally exactly the same thing so
you know the rarity is
the rarity is uh
is only because people are usually too
lazy to do that
um
so yeah i'm gonna
probably
uh thin this out a little bit
but i've ordered some samples and i i
think i'll announce it once i have these
samples ready
um
there's also one so it's it's usually
it's the same like it's the channel logo
on various items it's sort of the the
channel model which i don't usually
highlight but skill greater than destiny
is kind of the
i don't know it's been sort of a battle
cry
since i was young
um
it yeah
it's sort of it sort of
says that you can if you
if you dedicate yourself you can
overcome sort of the
maybe the hurdles of life whatever
it's a bit cheesy but
actually doesn't mean like if you take
it literally it's it it doesn't even
make sense right
and and because both are predetermined
like your skill is maybe predetermined
sure you can learn something but
and then your destiny is like ultimately
predetermined so if there is destiny you
can't change it but
um
maybe the paradoxical nature of it is
what makes it good and appealing
and obviously there is the attention for
you
if you're sewing if if you enjoy that
and
yeah i think that's i'm thinking
of a technology good technology bad
technology biased
uh motif as well
but that's that if you want to want to
do this
but as i said it's not announced yet
um it's going to change
and
there's also
there's there's more stuff coming out
in any case
let's like how do we how do we actually
generate
stuff from this
like okay we have a language modeling
head here but what do we have here
we have
an auto model also with
with a language modeling head
so we should we should provide some
inputs so let's say okay
how about we make our data set such that
it always starts with a queue
right like this
and then we could put here we could put
like q
i'm not making nfts no no
unless they actually become more useful
i'm not i'm not gonna make nfts don't
worry about that
um
so we got decoder input ids
yes
outputs wait that's what that's what we
that's what we did
oh okay
oh no wait
is it really
can we
do that
um
um okay
well
good
yes
most definitely
totally
it's a good model so far
okay how do i um
the hugging face trainer
you know how do i control it's it's
logging
how do i control it
log level log level replica
like how often how often it logs
um
yep yep
the logging frequency yes that's what i
want
frequency
hey where is it
can't find it
where is it
okay i know
logging steps
does this exist
ah there we go logging steps
number of update steps between two logs
if logging strategy equals steps okay
so this is steps
and we'll just set it to
is this a trainer or is this the
training arguments
training arguments okay
so in our training arguments
wait we might want to reprocess the data
set right
and here
now let's
do this
because
oh no it's being tokenized like that
sorry sorry
okay
training arguments
logging
steps 10
train
yes please
and
now we should finally see something
here
hopefully please
runs
this is green so this means it's going
yes
yay
and we are decreasing in loss excellent
oh wait i need to catch up
in chat
for how long will you stream not for too
much longer
so
maybe last year during i remember during
christmas
uh
you know everything's kinda stand still
during christmas right and i remember
pewdiepie streaming and i thought ah
that's neat cuz
you know nothing else is going on so
and
yeah so i i thought i'd do the same
thing and maybe someone
will appreciate it
or just be sort of mildly entertained
while they search for other content
will it be delivered all over the planet
the merch
i think so so i've deliberately
i first wanted to go with a different
like with um
what was it
i don't remember the other one but there
was another one that could be integrated
with youtube but they are not shipping
to india
right now which kind of i thought kind
of sucked
so
i think the teespring should be able to
ship anywhere
[Music]
don't feed don't feed in the decoder
input ids manually
it makes the outputs go weird well it
won't let me do anything else
yeah so i've i have not done hugging
face training in a long time uh from
scratch so
but this is just the first the first
instance
so we should be
yay
yeah we're we're nicely decreasing
nah not towards the end here
is this one epoch
three epochs
okay
batch size of eight
yeah that works out
per epoch
and then we'll see what happens
in 35 seconds
so
[Music]
do not forget to share your model i
don't think this model is uh necessarily
the best to be shared
okay
so we still
we're still
kind of
yep
so the model isn't the best right now
what data set are you using it's squad
so we're using squad but i think this
would be
sort of the process
um
a sort of the process to get this
started right
i mean what if i just don't do anything
here
what does it do it just gives me like an
end of end of sentence immediately
is this to be expected does the
does this even need an end of sentence
not sure
so the question does does the model is
the model initializing
like if i reset the model
like
like this
then
okay this is a lot of output
if i do that and then train again
what happens
yeah okay
no i don't want to learn about the
newest weights and biases updates
because
i make ads for them
i should know about the newest features
and updates
so this is better right now because
before we just kept retraining the same
model right
um
and not re-initializing it
and now at least we're at least we're
re-initializing it
see this was like our global step was uh
we just kept resetting the same model
but now
now
you see
do we have is this the
is the one that we currently have no
we'll see in a bit once it sinks
but even if not you can see here
loss is going down quite nicely
anyone know if one to be self-hosting is
fairly seamless training on a local gpu
server to watch progress
so the i think that
like
i might be wrong but the the
self-hosting for 1db is is mostly a
thing you do as a as a company
it's not it it's not the same as like
it's not like you know here is our open
source tool and you know we also host it
for you if you want they sort of take
the the different approach it's it's
cloud first
and if you're
if you're a business and you say well i
really need the data to stay in my
in my in my data centers in my own
uh environment then they'll give they'll
they'll give you
sort of a self-hosted environment
um i don't know how easy it is though to
get to one if you just say well i'm an
individual and i'm just
maybe yeah
i don't know but
i guess you can ask them
so soon
we should have this done
and then we can see then we'll have a
model that's kind of trained from
scratch
that shouldn't be too bad now
this is for research you're working on
just trying out something this is just
trying out something i haven't done i
haven't actually done
nlp coding in a while
so
and
i just randomly wanted to
or i just randomly thought that i might
might as well livestream it
know maybe we're not we're not doing a
whole lot here
we'll see
so we got
375 steps we're almost done
do we get some metrics here in the
meantime
not yet maybe i need to give it a
different name though right
i think
like because i'm i'm always logging to
the same name that can't be too good
what am i working on right now
uh
i've co-founded a startup an nlp startup
ironically right which
means that i work with a lot of smart
people that also know nlp therefore
i don't get to code nlp
anymore i get the code
i get to code mostly
plumbing
okay so
so
as you can see
let me
train
yeah let me get a data point from here
and
we'll take this right here
and we'll
we'll make our
repair data
of this one
how do we call it
process data of course
is there any model for transformers that
don't need n-squared
paper
uh
no
but they do have pseudo code i believe
in the paper itself
how does your day look like
uh it's a wild mess of whatever burns
the most it's i do not advise
i do not advise following my daily
routine
okay so let's call this
x1
and let's input that into the model
so
x1
input ids
not enough values to unpack where how
why no what come on
come on man
um
we'll do
this
list uh it needs to be a tenser so
that
beautiful
uh uh
[Music]
our model is terrible
how and why
right
it just
baffles me what if we don't train it at
all
right like what if uh
what if we just load the model
and we'll just input
this
how many steps do you usually train for
an image classification task or an image
reconstruction do you use smaller large
batch sizes
i
i don't i don't have a general recipe
you just go with whatever is is
appropriate uh and it also depends
really on the task so for unsupervised
learning people do hundreds of epochs
for imagenet i guess you can get away
with a bit less i think like 50 epochs
or something like this but also for
yeah it's it's really i know c4 10 or so
people use
50 to 250 epochs which is like a lot
right but then heavy augmentation
um it's really depends fully on the task
yeah
tell us about your startup sure it's
called deep judge it's very cliche name
and we do nlp for
the legal domain and if you're allowed
to work in the european union no well if
you
if you
are allowed to work in switzerland
uh
and you want to work in switzerland
and you're skilled in engineering
with an affinity for machine learning
you may you can happily apply
that is uh so
yes
let's see if google finds us yes of
course google finds us
okay
that is us
me wondering what i missed you didn't
miss anything it's just me it's just me
around in this
[Music]
okay so it seems like we haven't trained
anything
if
or or i'm just i'm just doing this
completely wrong i might want to look up
some more tutorials i've just
jumped into this uh completely but what
you can what we can do what we can do is
you can see that the
this x1 that we have right here right so
the first data point
and this is usually a good thing to do
if you wonder if your model works at all
so
we take the training data set right
we look at this data point
and the context is whatever
architecturally the school has a
catholic character yada yada
the question is to whom did the virgin
mary allegedly appear in da da da da
and the answer is saint bernadette
whatever
now
what we can do is we can uh completely
overfit on that one data point right
that that is
that is what we're going to do
and
for that let's restart the runtime first
and foremost
then we'll run this these things
run this
and when it comes to
the data set
we are going to
so process data right here
and then
when it comes to the data set we're just
going to select
one data point right
uh and we'll call that
overfit data set i'm going to take the
training data point i want to just get
one single
data point out of it we won't even we
won't even touch those right here
dataset is not defined
of course
why would it be because i need to run
this
okay
so
da dum
okay
so we'll get our overfit data set and
then we'll just we'll just train on that
overfit data set and how where is the
number of epochs
oh
num train epochs is three
we'll just put this to
um
num
train epochs
is i don't know like
a hundred or so
we'll just overfit on this one data
point
heavily
and instead of the training data set
being the training data set
we'll make train data set is overfit
data set
and eval data set
is also the overfit data set
overfit data set is not defined
data set
i see
so if this works out
imagenet is 100 to 600 epochs 50 isn't
really possible okay
if your judgment doesn't work claim it
is a company secret
training wait already completed
this is not this is
that is shady okay
let's try
see okay we're doing i'm doing something
terribly wrong
or we'll just put the number of
epochs to ten thousand
do we have output
please
do i need to rename
i should
probably rename right ah see okay this
is the output
now we're continuing
yeah
we're overfitting nicely
have you tested out the extreme
overfitting approach leading to super
convergence you talked a while back you
mean the grocking
yeah i think this will be a
different different domain right here
but i haven't i haven't actually done or
investigated grocking any time myself it
seems super interesting though yeah
change the name of 1db thing yeah i
should
i see no problem with training equals
are you going to do a more classic paper
review
um yes yeah this is this is also planned
um
the classics
why do you look like basils
it's uh
whenever the hair gets long longer it
just gets on my nerves
are you loading all the data
i am but right now i'm just loading a
single data point so
remove the end of sentence token
true that could be but this isn't this
part of the
i've just seen this on like one example
i might be
wrong
a great masculine job
what's the secret of the glasses that
there's no there's no secret it's just
that
it was a it was a
maybe bad branding decision
and now it's i'm stuck with them so
so see but now you can you can see that
we we are
we are
converging in
yeah look at that i mean
what is what is this do we we don't have
validation stuff okay but
ah
training
total f
training runtime
loss
this one right here i mean look at that
that is just very
low very very small
loss
so we got a thousand a thousand steps um
we might as well sort of interrupt what
is this clear output no we might as well
interrupt a little bit hey would you
would you mind
stopping
just
interrupting a bit
stop
okay
and
we'll just check the output maybe it's
something better now
still no
hmm
are we doing something wrong
hong kong
am i doing something wrong i'm probably
doing something wrong
are you hiring yes we're hiring
um
but you need to be able to work in in
switzerland which is
it sucks and it's not
available to most to most of the world
because of legal reasons but
we we have no choice really
um so you need to be able to get a
working permission
and yes this still sucks even though
we've completely overfit which means
that we're i'm doing something
quite wrong
the question is what
what's so wrong
may i may not i may not use this in the
exact correct way right here
so
um
i could sample i guess
so do sample is
but
the arg max it should be
good if we over fit so
uh-huh
the problem is that
we might just remove these end of
sentence tokens right
because
like white y
let's restart
and
this is the last try if this doesn't
work we'll just take the loss
so
we'll remove the end of sentence tokens
like
this and let's hope the tokenizer
puts them in itself
like that
good
and we'll do the thousand epochs again
and there we go
okay last run for
today wrong input yeah
yeah we can inspect train data set
entries after process data apply that's
a good idea we should do that as well
i don't understand the meaning of the
output can anyone explain no no one can
explain
that's it's it's it's not the desired
output we're trying to predict text
and
right now we're just it's it's garbage
so
but what we're trying to do is overfit
let's see
i could change this
also
overfitting on one data point
we're just trying we're just
just a bunch of researchers giving our
best
your input is from the full data set
what i mean
but i i take i just select the first
entry like i i do select
i select this entry
you're predicting the text from your
full data set but not from overfitting
data set
yeah but the the overfitting data set is
taking
it's taking the
it's taking the first data point right
the overfit data set
selects
exactly
the first data set
the first data point
so it selects the zero
of the train data set so this should be
the same i can i can try to just input
um
i could try to input yeah i see
is there a reason you're overfitting yes
it's because it's a good way to see
if you don't have
like it's a good way to catch bugs
so what you want to do is you want to
take a single data point
and then overfit to it
and if you can do that
it means that your model
is
okay or well it means your model
can at least process data that's
essentially what it means
uh but for us right now so let's let's
call that x2
overfit data set zero
right so
um x2
is now
it's a
whole lot a lot of
zeros zero zero zero zero
no it's actually it's actually okay it's
more than zeros um
we can decode it
uh
tokenizer decode
x to
input ids
let's see if that
yeah architecturally the school has a
catholic character
right this is fine this is
and
the answer saint bernadette we might
oh this is here good so this is done
automatically we don't have to do this
and then the pad
um maybe we'll leave away the pad
because right now we're padding right
and we technically don't need to pad or
we also grab the mask
yep maybe the masking is is the problem
and label ids
yeah
this is fine
and if we input now this into
let's input this
so we'll take
x2 right here
and
the decoder ids will input
nothing
list has no attribute to
what was x2 again
this is
just a list
we need to
okay
can we do this
i'm just i'm just hoping here nope
it's no attribute shape yeah we should
uh
we should
put it into a tensor
um
how to make a tensor from this do i need
to import pi torch
yeah probably
um
yep
so
okay
how
okay does anyone know how to make an
intention tensor
like this
how long
yep
okay yeah so
the output seems to be correct
but
we can't overfit
so
i have okay let's say we have a last
trick up our sleeves and that is
we remove the padding
so the model will just have to
take whatever we have it so the padding
we don't pad
we just truncate
all right
okay
how's it coming in
excellent
loss is decreasing
that is a good sign
and it's going to take another
90 seconds
does anyone know how janik deletes a
chunk of text with one button
it's probably you mean like the entire
line like this
it's uh
oh no
it's a vim command
it's capital
s uh
tim is calling me i should
i should leave soon
we're making we're making the
the final argument the final
things for the next machine learning
street talk
all right
done soon
you mentioned me as an inspiration for
your master's application to eth
nice
but
i don't i don't think human resources is
too happy with me
given that they've received calls in the
past about my behavior
so so maybe maybe don't don't mention
that too much
um
okay
i mean
you know
no
to sample true
some things something's wrong
like something's clearly wrong
i don't know what but
i'm doing something wrong with the with
the inputs right here
um
like this is
because it's
yeah
so i'm i'm not sure what exactly
what exactly they
are
what exactly they need but
here fine tuning t5
um
a mixture of supervised so here in
supervised training
right that's what they do
they have input ids
they have labels
um
now they have labels and not label ids
the function automatically creates the
correct decoder input
ids but you see you see this
it seems weird because i'm not putting
it and they
hmm
yes something is something is definitely
wrong so
labels let's call it
labels right
oh no
i was calling it labels all along
label ids labels label ids
labels
well
decoder ids
it's worth a try
i mean
we might just try it until here
might be the parameter where you can
auto add the end token yes yeah
true
um
yeah here
you generate
so
um
let's try
and instead of
yeah here i have labels too
oh that's what i just changed a second
ago i see
sorry for being dumb
no but here
labels right
cell is already running okay
okay
what's your opinion on jax
um
given that it has a built in
if i understand i have not looked into
jacks but if i understand correctly as a
built-in
xla compiler which is really good if you
want to do super custom stuff in pytorch
uh sorry on tpus which
i don't
um but i i as far as i've seen so far i
do like sort of the
it's much more clean
um
so
you know maybe if they put up a bit more
attention also on common usability not
just with tpus i guess
it might be a cool language
any good suggestion for a master's
in nlp i have no idea sorry i've chosen
my university
because it was the only one in the
country that was like
it was that was that was a
had the things that i wanted to
or that i was interested in vaguely
see got an unexpected labels why okay
how no
decoder
ids
okay
all right
maybe now
labels yeah no
what was it before decoder ids right
decoder input ids
that's better
that is better
no you don't think so
catholic catholic
and what did we want to whom did the
virgin mary allegedly appear it's better
than before
no a two
did we say do sample true
now it just devolves again
i might be imagining that this is better
than before
but it has the end of in the main main
of the main building
i might be imagining that this is better
maybe also because it we trained it for
not as long
oh
a look at that
look at that
yeah
okay
decoder ids
whatever
that
means
but if i don't do decoder input ids but
decoder ids
i get the correct question so we can in
fact overfit
on a single data point
um
see
this is the output
it is the output yes
it's padded to the left for whatever
reason
but it is the output and what if i put
like a q
here
excellent
so it turns out that the most
challenging part about doing machine
learning is using the correct keyword
arguments in the hogging face library
coincidentally this would be something
where like copilot would be a killer at
i've been i've been using this for a
while now and it's at this kind of stuff
it's really good
so
yes so that that was
essentially
this was where i wanted to get to today
we have a model that can take in
question sorry context
context
answer pairs and give us questions
the next step is to take this
and
make this
train it on squad
then generate
a data set of more questions and answers
and then we can use that to train
another question answering model
and
it at the end of it that one should be
better than our original one that we
just trained on the data set alone which
is a little bit magic because we don't
introduce new data right
we don't
but what we do what we can do is
you know we always need
we need new question answer pairs
so the input to this model is going to
be
a
context and an answer and we let it
produce a question now the context we
just take from the same data set but
what is the answer
that is um
that is the question well ironically
that is the question so what we can do
is we can use something like a
um
maybe like a sequence tagger maybe from
from spacey or so that recognizes nouns
or noun phrases in
the context and then we'll just take
these noun phrases as possible answers
so what these papers this is not my idea
right these are papers that that are in
question answering what they do is they
would find noun phrases
they would let this model that they've
trained to produce questions produce a
question given the context and this
possible answer then they use the
original question answering model to
check whether it actually gets it right
and that's how they they generate new
data
that's essentially what we're going to
do
but
yeah this was it for for today's live
stream uh i
it took it took a bit longer but it's
good to
refresh myself as well
because as i said i've been doing mostly
plumbing coding and not machine learning
coding so this is fun and i hope
uh
i hope at least someone
someone
learned about the trick of overfitting
on a single data point um
because i remember when i for when first
someone told this to me i was like oh
wow this is
this is really helpful
and i'm sure most people know it by now
but it's still super helpful
all right so in this case thank you very
much to everyone who's
who's been here
um
i need to hop on a call with with tim
and keith for the street talk
and yeah i'll see you around thank you
so much
and bye bye